the first question this was a quadratic
inequality so you can see that all you
have to do to begin with it's a little
bit of rearrangement get everything over
on the left hand side so you can treat
that quadratic just as a quadratic on
its own and then from this line to this
slide do whatever you need to in order
to get this into a factorized form you
should have a look at you can see 3
times 30 is 90 you have a 13 in the
middle bitterly 19 is right up at the
ceiling I'd say of numbers I'd expect
you they will break into factors
reasonably quickly but 5 and 18 you
shouldn't be able to shouldn't take you
too long to work out that's the combo
that will give you 13 so therefore you
can see I've broken apart this guy into
two do you agree with that and this
second line is clearly superior because
now with four terms I can break it apart
into pairs and then off I go okay now
this is important here I factorize but
that's not the solution in my head what
I've got is this is a fairly ordinary
looking happy parabola right so in my
head over here I'd say okay it looks
something like this right what this
tells me is where these two points of
intersection are over there one is going
to be negative 6 part of my scale this
one's gonna be 5 over 3 the question is
asking when is this parabola less than
or equal to 0
so the part that I'm interested in is
gonna be this part down here do you
agree and that's why it's between
negative 6 and 5/3 which is what gives
you 9
thumbs up yeah okay
sample view this next month this is just
on number right I mean you had to crunch
out Pythagoras theorem
did I do my numbers right what do you
think 104
I admit even I myself I didn't write
this particular quiz some of them I did
write this particular one I didn't and I
looked at that 104 and I looked at it
sideways and thought did I do something
from home
you expect the square number but I
checked it all that you should have
noticed these two things here I know
they're busy right but you can see
number one if you write it just as a
third on its own without the true out
the front then squaring it becomes a
little bit easier right secondly because
these two things are actually not just
rated they are start to the seat didn't
know what those cool like hold when
you've got a plus in them you're gonna -
we call them conjugates right so
conjugates come up all the time we use
them in rationalizing denominators and
so on but what you notice is nice about
them is that these two terms here are
the messy ones they just cancel out so
you shouldn't have have any cert when
you get to this line they just take the
square roots of both sides so that was
the value I got okay now i'm run your
eyes down this list can you read that is
that big enough to read yeah now number
one in binomial theorem and number two
when we start to do calculus which is
differentiating and integrating all
these things for later on this kind of
conversion into index form you've got to
be able to do that in your sleep
seriously I know some of these get messy
later on but there's really only two
tricky things that happen there are
certain so for example the four through
no no bar in that number raised to the
power R
our quota right so that's why this is
quota cultural and then when you've got
things on the denominators
it's just that negative index so what do
you think did I make any errors or are
you happy with them are there anything
you see now what then yeah we'd put on
minus five times and then in brackets
three squared three x squared all to the
minus one hmm oh I see
sorry you're saying this minus five
outside of three x squared to the one is
that what you say yeah yeah sure
what I would say is that is not wrong
but it also isn't what the question is
asking right the single expressions in
index form you've written that broken
apart clearly there's a problem with
this part here right that the question
is is implying to you look you can write
that as one thing and so you should just
like these questions down here are
asking you to compile I wouldn't a set x
times X to the power of 1/2 that's not a
single expression it index form so a
pocket I wouldn't accept I wouldn't have
said that that's what this question is
about be able to manipulate and simplify
that so therefore you're gonna be
expected to go I wouldn't mind
I wouldn't mind this minus 5x to the
minus 203 I think that's materially
identical to this but I don't think that
those two are identical I think there's
a little bit of extra legwork you should
put in there okay all right if I just
zoom out can you see to the bottom is
that last one I then yeah what do you
think Joe - hold on a bit longer as you
mom
[Music]
so I went through eggs of an excellent
root X over X I mean it's true it's not
your next visit
any more questions
okay if you haven't if you've missed
some of those that's okay I'll come back
to these if you need me to but let's uh
let's move on alright oops here we go so
here we go
this is a simple factorial
simplification thinking back is only
only two things you have to do if that
so you can see there's a few terms in
there that I've throw it in just to see
if you can identify which is the ones
that matter which is the important ones
so what I've looked at is the biggest
factorial so I can find because the
biggest ones will give me the most I can
cancel on the denominator do you see why
I've I've enrolled this just one step
you see why what am I trying to get out
I'm trying to find the N factorial cuz I
can see that on the top and I know
that's the biggest one there because
this n minus 1 factorial like this might
be 10 factorial about make this knife
right so it's smaller it's gonna be
little bit less interest to me okay so I
just unroll this thing on the bottom the
N factorial ski and here cancel and then
once you get to there that's it .
nothing else you can do